hey guys this is andrew for drinking
census.com so for those who are watching
my video for the first time i've been
working as a professional trader for the
past six years in hong kong
and i'm using technical analysis every
day to help me to take any trading
decision
and in my videos i want to show you guys
how to do it yourself so today
let's make a complete analysis of amc
and i'm going to show you
all the different techniques that you
can use to predict the price action
let's get into it
[Music]
all right guys so we are on the amc
chart as usual we start on the fourth
time frame
so i'm gonna go step by step i'm gonna
use all the different techniques
and i'm gonna try to conclude what
would happen sooner i'm also gonna go
quickly through the option interest
because i'm an option trader and i think
this information is very valuable if you
know how to read it
so first let's start with technical
analysis
moving averages so when you want to use
moving averages
you guys need to go from one time frame
to the other one
and you need to focus on the recent past
so when you look at this price action so
this was the last two days of the week
uh you can see that we were ranging
between like let's say 10 50 and
nine right in this area but each time we
were actually
supported by the 200 period moving
average on the force time frame which
is the best time frame and the best
moving average to use i'm using simple
moving average you can use exponential
moving averages it works as well
the only thing is that you need to check
if you have good reactions in the past
so only when i look at moving averages
we are bullish and we can see that
200 period one is holding the price
quite well now i go on a daily
i do the same thing i've done this get
with you guys before ready
and you can see that you have no new
information because you have the same
reaction with the 50 period moving
average on the daily time frame so
no new information here and go back on
the flower stamp frame because
it's the time frame where i think you
can see things the best
let's do some idiot wave counting all
right so eager to have counseling for
those who
don't know what it is it's just about
trying to break down
the price action in waves moves up
developing five waves one two three four
five and moves down developing three
waves
abc can be a zigzag a flat and sometimes
a triangle
so here when i do this exercise
my scenario is that this is a one this
is a two
somewhere here then we have three four
five alright
so
something like this
and the question i'm having is is the
wave 2 complete or not
so to answer this question you have
different techniques the first technique
is using trend lines
when i connect the two recent highs that
i have in my second wave that is
here the abc i actually
find the breakout that i showed you guys
already
that is a typical breakout here you
break it out
you retest so if you guys want to go
long on the stock
this is the level you need to buy and
here you can see that you have a double
signal because you had
the retest of the breakout and the
support level was also given you guys by
the 200 billion moving average on the
first time frame
so you could buy here at nine and you
had
actually several opportunities to buy
this level all right
so this is how you can use for example
trend lines to enter your trades
here the only question i'm having is is
this abc complete or not all right it's
it can be like this it can also be like
this
but for now what i'm seeing is that here
we broke out we
are trading you know we're having some
bullish development here with higher
highs
so i believe the second wave is done it
and it is here and so right now i think
that we are entering
this third wave right
that is supposed to do something like
this
the third wave are usually very
impulsive very long
so this is the only thing that i'm
missing here i'm missing some
volumes guys because usually during
third waves
you can see an increase in volume and
here if i go on a daily time frame to
check the volume
i can see that the volumes are slowly
picking up and slowly
this day was good it was a bullish day
but the next day
is not amazing if i go on the weekly
you can see that we had less shares
training this week
than the week before this is for now
not what we are looking for because we
want to see volumes going higher if we
are in a third wave
this would come so if it's not coming
for now we don't have the confirmation
we are in the
third wave so maybe we are still in this
second wave i'm just trying to show you
guys here
how i do my reasoning to try to guess if
yes or not the second wave is complete i
think it
is but i don't have all the signals for
now in green
here we are in the third wave then here
we are doing
same thing guys
okay so we're looking for something like
this for the coming week
so once again this is only the first
wave of the third of the third
so this is not supposed to be the
strongest one we're looking for a small
correction
and then we should have you know a very
bullish day so coming
around the 27th 28th of april
all right so if this is correct
we should see volumes picking up and
press action
doing higher highs like big moves up and
something else that you guys can use to
actually
see if the price action is bullish or
not is what we call
divergence all right so let me show you
quickly what is the divergence
so you have a few types of divergences
you have the regular divergence
let's take the bullish case so here is
your price action and here is your
momentum indicator
when the price action is going lower and
the momentum indicator is going
higher for example i use the macd you
can use rsi stochastic
as well it's working well this means
that basically
the price action is going lower but
you already have some shift in the
momentum because the macd which is a
momentum indicator which is showing you
who is in control
is going higher it means that this law
is less
intense than the previous one and this
is meaning that the market is out of
steam and that usually a reversal
is about to come then you have the
hidden divergence
so let's focus on the bullish one as
well is when the market is making
higher lows but with a momentum
indicator that is
making low lows which means that the
bearish momentum
is growing and despite the growing
bearish momentum
the price action holds above the first
low
and manages to make a new higher low
so this is actually giving you a signal
that bears are no more that much in
control and that
both start to gain confidence and
usually
this is a signal that the market is
going to shift
higher okay so keep this in mind we go
back to the charts
and here i showed you guys this already
but i think it's very important that
everybody sees it
so i'm gonna say it again you know it's
never bad
to see the same things twice so here
guys we focus
on the macd and the chart so i'm
going to start on the daily timeframe i
connect the slow and the slow
and you can see that we're making higher
lows then we're going to check what is
the max doing during this
period and you can see that the macd is
going from here
it's 19th of feb so it's here
to here all right so we go from
0.15 to minus 0.2 so we are actually
going lower when the price action is
going higher so we have a hidden
divergence on the long term
so this is telling me that on the long
run we are
bullish so there is no guarantee of
course but this is just
one more indication that is going to the
same conclusion
that we are probably done with the
second wave and that we are in the third
wave development
of course if suddenly we see the price
action
dropping much lower and making lower low
which
is very unexpected then the hidden
divergence would not be here anymore
so careful those signals can disappear
suddenly i mean
you know for now we're having it but for
example if we don't have it anymore this
could be a signal that the momentum is
shifting as well
so keep an eye on this and on the
shorter term
if i'm going to force time frame what do
i have guys what do i have
try to see it as well so don't focus too
much on my drawings focus on the chart
and we are looking for momentum shifts
the momentum here
is bearish so we're gonna connect the
lows
all right so we're making lower lows
but what is the magnitude doing guys the
macd
is making higher lows all right this is
a regular divergence
this means that actually the momentum is
shifting
here because the price action is going
lower but with less momentum
you can see that basically this move was
much
stronger than this move so this is kind
of you know you can even
see divergences without the macd once
you are
used to what it means which is basically
meaning that the market
is just losing steam you can even spot
it
you know with your own eyes and this is
the reason why i like to use trend lines
because they're giving you those signals
as well
here for example when the market is
going higher and is actually breaking
out here i know that
you know after a strong move down here
this is going to give me
usually regular divergence so we're
having here two types of divergences on
two different time frames
which is bullish guys which is bullies
under four hours bullish on the daily we
have the
trend landing breakouts we have the
idiot wave counting that is clean
once again guys why is it clean because
you can see that
in every abc you know i can always
do some more abc's you know so this is
actually
what we call x y z correction w x y
sorry correction
so this is actually telling me that my
counting
makes sense so once again i'm not 100
sure
but just every technique i use for now
is leading me to the same conclusion
that
discounting is correct and that we are
developing in this
third wave and one last thing you can
use the macd just by itself
because actually guys the macd is a
green not
yet because the macd is something that
is used by a lot of institutional
clients a lot of
asset managers big money investors and
they basically just
you know wait for the magnitude to turn
green to enter the trade so they're
going to build
their trade idea based on fundamentals
they're going to use technicals to enter
the trades you know they just pay
some firms very expensively by the way
that just you know give them
basic information you know i work in a
bank and even my bank they
sometimes hire those guys that do
technical analysis i go to the meetings
and i can tell you
that i'm not the one asking questions
you know i can see that those guys are
just repeating
very basic stuff they're funding they
don't know how to use it
and still they're getting a lot of money
from the banks
to help them to invest so just
one way to see that technical analysis
even used in its most
basic ways is efficient otherwise banks
would not be paying those guys that
to me are newbies anyway here it's going
to come yeah it's going to come on
monday so monday
i'm pretty sure like around 95 that the
macd is going to turn
green and when it's going to turn green
usually
there is a lot of buying money coming
into the game and that is going to help
us to do this
third wave so everything looks very
good to me now let's go quickly on the
news
you know if you want to understand why
amc went up you know this week
you just check some articles and most of
the things i find
is stuff like this shares of amc were
rising
7.8 in morning trading thursday on
no news specific to the theater operator
though there were progress being made on
the corona virus front
all right the truth is guys when the
market is bullish there is no news so
you know those analysts
they try to find something to understand
why the market is going up but there is
no reason the market wants to go up
it's the momentum that is shifting it's
bulls getting confidence
every news will be interpreted better
whatever
it is but still it's interesting to see
that there is no news
and that is just about the covida so
let's have a look at the copy guys this
is you know i like to use this website
uh will do matters and you can see you
know all the
information about the copied so what i
like to check so this is for the united
states
the daily new cases this is a good
information so there is more and more
vaccine
and you can see that here we have this
one two three four five so i know
you know eliot wave can be applied to
anything so i'm not saying that this
would work here but we're having this
first wave
that is definitely complete and now
we're having a kind of
abc you know so it looks good to me it
looks like you know it really wants to
go down
i mean just looking at this here same
thing one two three four five
and then here we are definitely
correcting
slightly going higher it's important to
see what is going to happen here in the
active cases for now there are still
6.8 million but i'm expecting them to
drop because we have the vaccine coming
just looking at those curves i know guys
i'm not a scientist i have no clue
if yes or not they're gonna be more
variants or whatever
i'm just looking at those curves and
they look like
it's decreasing and it's going better so
it's good news and one last thing i want
to show you guys in this video
i take the open interest guys i found it
on yahoo finance i record everything
here
i basically like to compute the
synthetic short interest that is used on
the cool options when
retail investors are buying collapsions
they actually getting a long position
in front of market makers or hedge funds
that are left
short so this is a short position that
you don't see in the reports of
finra and this is additional short
interest and i like to check what is
happening here
so what i do i take all the maturities
you can see
all the maturities until july i take all
the open interest i compute the delta
the delta is the exposure of
each option i use this formula guys if
you have questions just ask me you know
it's just formula like
this you see there's this kind of
formula so i use it
myself you know i rebuilt my exposure
and i can tell you guys that for now
we're having five percent of synthetic
short and the total open interest
converted in shares equivalent is 12
so it's a lot but for example it's not
as much as gamestop where we have 21
if market is going really higher and you
can see that those call options
are mostly at the 10 strike level and
you also have some at the 40 strike
level
if amc goes higher let's say to 15
because 15 is very
reasonable the short interest goes to 8
so this is
what we call the gamma and this is going
to push market makers to buy
more shares if amc goes higher and i
have all the reason to think
amc would go higher and so those guys
they're going to add some
bullish momentum so that's it for me
i hope you guys enjoyed this video and
if you did please don't forget to click
on the sub
like and bell button so you're gonna be
the first to know when i upload anything
new
and stay close to show i'll see you guys